JOHN STOKES: Welcome to this
edition of Google Authors
Talks with Chris Cheng.
I am John Stokes.
And normally, if
I'm at Google HQ,
I am sitting out
there in the audience
live blogging about
a Nexus phone,
or trying to think of
good questions to ask.
But this time, I
get to be on stage.
If you know me, you
probably know me
as one of the founders
of Ars Technica.
And I've also, in the past,
done some work for Wired,
and a couple of other
tech publications.
And now, weirdly enough, I'm
kind of a gun guy like Chris.
And we'll talk a
little bit about how
I made that transition,
and how he made it.
Chris, some of you
probably know him.
He is a former Googler,
a member of the Google
Apps for Enterprise team.
And while he was
on that team, he
entered and won History
Channel's "Top Shot"
Season Four Championship.
And if you're not
familiar with "Top Shot,"
we're going show
a clip, I believe.
CHRIS CHENG: Yup.
JOHN STOKES: OK, we're
going to show a clip.
It's a reality show
elimination type
of competition, where
the participants compete,
and they shoot lots of
different kinds of projectiles
at lots of different
kinds of targets.
And so Chris has shot everything
from grenade launchers
to spear chuckers, and
so on, and so forth.
And he competed against some
pretty serious marksmen,
and he went on as
an amateur and won.
And it's a pretty cool
story of how he did that.
And now he is sponsored
by Bass Pro Shops.
He's a professional marksman.
And he is also an
NRA commentator,
and he has a new
book, "Shoot To Win."
And so we're going to be
talking about some things
from the book.
I got a chance to read it,
and it's a great introduction
to firearms and to
firearm culture, and also,
interestingly enough, to
the kinds of techniques that
allowed Chris to
go on to "Top Shot"
and beat the pants off of people
who were very, very experienced
marksmen.
So we're just going to do
a really informal QA style
interview format.
And I'm just going to
be bouncing questions
off Chris here.
CHRIS CHENG: And there will
be opportunities for audience
participation, so if
you have any questions,
you can definitely feel free
to-- we'll have opportunities
for Q and A from the audience.
JOHN STOKES: Yeah, absolutely.
So Chris, one of the themes
in the book that really
is super predominant is the
sort of power of the internet
to teach you anything
you want to know now,
especially YouTube, and
forums, and things like this.
And it's sort of I think of it
as the rise of the autodidact
and the rise of the self-taught
person as an expert.
And so not only can you teach
yourself anything on YouTube
now-- I taught myself
how to barbecue
by watching YouTube videos.
And my daughter thinks
I'm a master pizza chef,
and I just watched
a bunch of YouTube.
But you can do it to a very
high degree competency.
You can train yourself to
a high degree of competency
in the privacy of your
own apartment or whatever,
just on the internet.
And historically gun culture--
that's not how it works.
Knowledge about guns,
about firearms, safety,
maintenance, when to shoot, how
to shoot, why to shoot-- this
is something that's passed on
typically from father to son,
because it's very male
dominant, although that's
changing rapidly.
But it's passed on.
It's a relational
kind of knowledge.
It's steeped in
tradition and heritage,
and so you kind of parachuted
in off the internet.
You're like this
internet-powered, YouTube,
self-taught, goal-oriented,
project-oriented person.
You're, like, here's a project.
I'm going to tackle it.
I'm going to optimize
this and that.
I'm going to train myself.
And you just show up
in this competition
with these people who are kind
of heritage type of people,
and then you beat them.
And there's got be some kind
of backlash or culture clash
there.
And I was wondering if you
could speak to that difference.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, I think
it at a very high level,
it was really interesting
to approach a subject that I
didn't know a lot about,
which was marksmanship.
And I mean, I learned how
to shoot when I was six,
and my father taught
me how to shoot.
But growing up in
Southern California,
it wasn't an activity
that we did all the time.
It just wasn't a very strong
or active gun culture.
And it's just amazing to see how
much information is on the web,
and the huge role that Google
has played in providing people
with a platform, and
giving people a voice,
too, to say what they want
to say, teach other people.
And it's all about sharing
knowledge and learning.
And I'm a lifelong
student of the philosophy
that we're lifelong learners,
and that you're never
too old to learn something new.
And there's certain
types of people
who either get really
excited about the unknown,
and they just dive in, and
learn as much they can.
And there's other people who
get intimidated by the things
that they don't know, the fact
that they may not be as good,
or they may not be good at
all at a certain activity.
And I just have always wanted
to learn as much as I can,
and get as good as I can about
things as quickly as possible.
And so YouTube and the web
was a primary way for me
to learn about marksmanship.
I didn't have a lot of
friends or colleagues
here at Google that
shot guns, and so I
didn't have a lot of that
sort of in-person interaction
and knowledge transfer
from other people,
like face to face.
I mean, I did have that
to a certain extent,
but the web was a huge,
important resource for me
to learn about marksmanship
and training for "Top Shot."
JOHN STOKES: Could
you talk a little bit
about some of the specific
resources that you used?
Were there any YouTube
channels that you can just
throw out there real
quick for reference
for them to go back and look?
CHRIS CHENG: Gosh, I mean,
I was just, like, scouring.
It's just one of those
exercises where I didn't even
know what I didn't know.
So I was just seeing
it all-- everything
from beginning marksmanship to
the advanced stuff, semi auto
pistols, fully automatic,
fully automatic rifles,
and trying to then parse
through all of this data,
and try and figure
out, OK, how do I
whittle down this
massive body of knowledge
and pare it down to the
core essentials of what
will help me win Top Shot?
And so I don't remember,
like, specific sites,
just because I
was so overwhelmed
with-- I was
watching FPS Russia.
If you're familiar
with FPS Russia--
he's a YouTube personality.
I think he's got, I don't
know, a gillion followers.
And he just blows stuff up.
And so that's just
a lot of fun--
not so much educational,
but just more
entertainment and a good time.
But there's a lot of
discussion forums,
and a lot of journalists who
also write about firearms,
technique, and tactics.
And it was just
fascinating that whatever
topic that we want
to learn about,
there are all these
micro communities
online that we can dive in
and learn as much or as little
as we want.
JOHN STOKES: Yeah, I
don't think growing up,
I would've ever thought
that the skill set of here's
a giant mass of relatively
unstructured information.
How do I sort it by
usefulness, and how do I
learn to process it and
weed out what's irrelevant?
I would never lump
that in as one
of the marksmanship
fundamentals.
This is not the kind
of thing that you
think of as, I want
to learn to shoot,
or I want to learn
to cook, or whatever
it is that you're doing.
But it's fascinating that that
skill set is now a component,
especially if you're
going to go this route.
And that's actually what I
did a lot as a journalist
for Ars Technica and for
"Wired," was you go out,
and you look, and you
process information.
You try to figure out what's
relevant, and what's not,
and throw out the
irrelevant stuff.
And I think that kind of skill
set has to be democratized.
The more people that can
do it, the more people
can teach themselves.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, something
that I always continually think
about my time here at
Google, and just the skill
sets that I gained from
my experience working
in customer support
and technical support.
And I mean, all of
us here, I mean,
I know your inboxes just get
flooded with hundreds of emails
a day, and not just your
inbox, but Buganizer,
and you've got all sorts
of other internal tools.
You've got all these
signals coming at you.
And applying that
skill set of how do you
filter out the
low priority noise
and prioritize, OK, what are the
things that I need to do either
right now, or from your team
perspective, what are the most
important things that our team
should be focusing on to build
the product, product
enhancements,
et cetera, et cetera?
And we're all busy people.
It doesn't matter what
industry you're in.
I think that it's a
good, general skill set
to apply to all
parts of your life.
And that's a big part of what
I talk about in the book.
The book, "Shoot To
Win," is not just
a book about beginning
marksmanship.
It's about how I took work
skills that I learned here
at Google, and I'm a musician,
and I played a lot of baseball
when I was a kid.
And so taking these
other skill sets,
and taking the frameworks,
and applying it
to other parts in
my life is a way
that I'm able to bring my full
skill set to a task at hand.
So I'm not, like
if I'm at work, I'm
not just thinking
about my work skills.
Or if I'm working on
a personal project,
I'm pulling from work
skills, oftentimes.
So I really want encourage
a multi-disciplinary kind
of cross-platform
approach, if you will,
to optimizing your own life.
JOHN STOKES: So let's go back
to the skill thing in a minute.
I want to hop
around, and ask you
about gun culture 1.0 and 2.0.
I don't know how many of
you guys sort of follow
this discussion, but there's
kind of gun culture 1.0,
which is hunting and the gun
should have a wooden stock,
and it should be, like,
single shot maybe.
And it's about sort
of outdoor-centric,
and there's not really
a competition focus.
And then there's
gun culture 2.0,
which is people that come in
to guns from "Call of Duty,"
or from the movies, or
something like this.
And the clothing
is more tactical,
and it's got that
more competition vibe.
And so there's
historically been a bit
of a clash between
the two kind of camps,
and that's narrowed quite a bit
in the past five years or so.
But Chris is very much a sort
of a more gun 2.0 kind of guy.
I was raised as a
gun 1.0 kind of guy,
and I was pretty hostile to the
2.0 guys with the black rifles.
I would go into a gun store, and
I would see these on the wall,
I would think, "What freak
buys that, because surely you
must have some kind of
weird James Bond fantasy."
And then eventually I got one,
and it's a lot of fun to shoot,
and my nerd gear
tech side kicked in.
I was, like, this is a gadget.
So I made that
transition myself.
And it's funny.
Most of my community--
I grew up in Louisiana,
in South Louisiana, and very
sporting-centric, hunting,
and camping, and stuff.
And one Christmas, I went
back and all of a sudden,
the guys were pulling
AR-15s out of the gun safe
and showing each other.
And that was kind
of a shock for me.
So that's happened
kind of rapidly,
and I was wondering if
you could speak to that.
Have you seen this
dichotomy, or kind of
lived on either side of it?
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, it's a
very interesting discussion
we have about the
1.0 versus 2.0 folks.
And for me, I love--
I've been hunting a lot.
I'm also a competition shooter.
But then I also
enjoy trap shooting,
which trap shooting is sort
of more in that 1.0 kind
old-school break-action shotgun.
It's very meditative, and
it requires your whole focus
to literally just do one thing
at a given moment in time.
And in the multitasking kind
of world that we live in,
being able to just be
disciplined and focused
on a single task
that's literally right
in front of your face-- that's
another skill set that I enjoy.
And so I have my feet
planted in both the 1.0
and the 2.0 worlds, because
when I'm at the trap range,
I hear some of these guys talk--
the guys with their AR-15s
and their race pistols that they
shoot really fast with red dot
sites, and all that stuff.
I think it's just
really exciting
to see 2.0 and
obviously, eventually,
the next phase, viewing
how our culture--
how gun culture will develop.
It is bringing in new
people into the sport.
And John had written
a really great article
for Wired talking
about how the AR-15 is
very similar to building
your own computer.
And the modularity
of each platform,
and how you can pick and
choose your hard drive,
and your graphics card, and
how much RAM, and so on.
And then on the
AR side of things,
what kind of bulk carrier
group, and trigger, and barrel.
And you can just geek
out as much as you want.
And the big picture for
me is that this is just
about having fun in a safe
and responsible manner,
and having productive
conversations about gun
culture.
And that what we see in the
news and in the media about how
bad people use guns
for bad things--
that is not the
full story, right?
What we see with gun
violence is statistically,
a very small
percentage of the way
that guns are being
used in America,
and that the
overwhelming majority--
I'm talking 98% or 99%
of gun-owning Americans
are law-abiding citizens who
are not causing any problems,
and not committing any crime.
So for me, this is about
the pursuit of the truth.
And if, as long as we
know what the truth is,
base whatever opinion you want,
but at least base your opinions
and perspectives
off of the facts.
And I guess I think a little
bit about how-- let's just
take an example.
So I mean, I'm gay.
And if you've never
met a gay person,
then you just have
an incomplete picture
of what the LGBT
community is about.
Then you can just
live in your own head
about what you think
gay people are.
And it's very similar
with gun people, right?
If you don't know
any gun owners,
if you've never shot
a gun, it's just
something that you are
not basing your opinions
and perspectives off of the
truth, whether it's facts,
or whether it's
in-person experience.
So that's a big part of my
involvement in gun culture,
is to shine the
light on the stories
in the gun community
that are not
being told in
traditional mass media.
JOHN STOKES: Yeah, it's funny.
I see some of that
myself as a media person
and as a gun person.
And actually, I'll go ahead
and jump into another question,
because we should talk briefly
about tragedy, because it
strikes with depressing
regularity right now.
And I find that when there's
a gun-related tragedy
in the news, I become
like a punching bag slash
lightning rod slash defendant
on trial for all gun people
everywhere amongst my friends.
And being a media
person, I have a lot
of friends who are not
comfortable with guns
or outright hostile.
And so I often find
that I kind of end up
having to have an answer
for a lot of these things.
And a lot of it, you end
up going on the defense,
and you're trying
to defend something
that's important to you.
And for me, it's
also-- for myself
it's a heritage thing,
because it's sort of the way
that I was raised.
And it's tied up
with my ancestors
and all this other
kind of thing.
But you end up trying to defend
on these different grounds.
And what I want from
gun people like myself
and from other gun
people is more of, OK,
what are we going to do to help?
What are the goals
that gut people
are going to work towards to
minimize these kinds of things?
Because there has
to be something
that can be done other
than, well, there's
a lot of proposals that
come out that are not
grounded in any basic
knowledge of firearms.
So a lot of you have seen this.
People that don't know,
like, a gun is a machine.
So people that don't
know the basics
about how these things work
will commonly produce proposals.
Well, this would
solve the problem,
or this would solve the
problem, or maybe we
should have some sort
of punitive tax on ammo,
or something like this.
And so they're not
plugged in enough.
And you would never
get away with that
if you were trying to propose
regulations around GMOs
or any other kind
of safety thing,
if you didn't know basics
about planting, and growing,
or genetics.
But you can kind of do
this in the gun world.
And so anyway, to go
back to it, I mean,
I personally have my
own opinions about what
gun people can do, but I'd like
to hear from Chris just sort
of what his take
on this issue is,
and how gun people can not
just be on the defensive,
but can be proactive
about addressing
just the whole spectrum of
gun violence-- crime, suicide,
mass shooting, all that stuff.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, it's
a really good question.
And at a very high
level, I think
the first step is, if
you're a gun owner--
or if you don't own a gun
but you support the Second
Amendment-- it's important
that you speak up.
And in the same way that
someone can't look at me
and know that I'm a gun
owner or know that I'm gay,
I have to be vocal about--
hey, if somebody starts saying
bad things about gay
people in front of me,
and they don't
know that I'm gay,
I'm going to say, hey, like,
you're talking to a gay person.
So in a very similar
way of there's
sort of a gay shaming and gun
shaming element that happens,
right?
So you're at the
office, and there's
some sort of mass
shooting event,
and someone starts
saying, oh my gosh,
we should just ban
AR-15s and whatnot.
And I mean, I've been in that
position, where it's like, OK,
do you keep your mouth shut?
And I understand, obviously,
your relationships
with your colleagues
are something
that you want to maintain.
But on the other hand,
you remaining silent
is, in a way, compliance,
and agreeing with someone
who you disagree with.
So I think first and
foremost, being vocal.
Number two, knowing
facts-- and I am really
trying to promote a thoughtful
discussion and dialogue that we
just do not see with
our politicians,
with policymakers-- and to be
honest, even just amongst us,
just regular citizens.
It's turned into this hyper
partisanship, extreme, just
extremism, where it's either
ban guns or no regulation
at all kind of discussion.
And I mean, the nuances
are interesting,
but at the very high
level, it's too much
of an emotionally driven
conversation most of the time.
And so one of my
focuses for gun violence
is actually suicide prevention.
And so for some of the
numbers-- in the United States,
there's approximately
30,000 people
who die at the hands of a gun.
Now 20,000 of
those are suicides,
and 10,000 are homicides.
So how are we looking at his
gun violence problem, where
the majority of gun deaths--
which are suicides-- and we
barely-- I don't
think anybody talks.
I won't say no one, but this
is not front and center in CNN,
and Fox News, and all
the other media outlets.
If you look at the 10,000
number for homicides,
a majority of that is gang
and criminal violence.
And so if we're going to
tackle the biggest problem,
well, let the data
dictate sort of where
we should put our focus.
And I think the suicide
prevention piece,
because it is so tightly
connected to firearm safety,
it's something I think
everyone can agree on,
that firearm safety
is important.
We want to protect people
from hurting themselves.
And I think there's
more areas like this
where look-- it's low
hanging fruit, potential
for high impact,
literally move the needle,
and reduce the number of
suicides in our country.
And I think if we spend more
time trying to work together
towards common
goals versus butting
heads all the time--
of course, there
will be times where, sure,
it's just going to happen.
You're going to but heads.
But I think our country is
in a place where we're not
trying to work together
as much as we should.
JOHN STOKES: I totally get that.
I mean, I am far to the
left of Barack Obama,
but I'm also a gun person.
And a lot of my
colleagues and friends
on the left-- I'm always trying
to get them to be, like, let's
not demonize.
Let's not stereotype.
Let's not be prejudiced.
Let's not demonize, because
there are a lot of gun owners
who are a lot more
moderate than you think,
and who are interested
in solutions.
And whenever all
gun-owners get lumped
together with the
crazies or with the mass
shooters or whatever,
it sort of contributes
to this polarization that is
totally counterproductive.
And not that I want
to say gun owners
are victims or
this kind of thing,
because that's the kind of
rhetoric that's also not
helpful-- when gun owners try
to paint themselves as victims
of some kind of
persecution thing.
But it's, like,
if everybody could
dial back down,
that would be great.
But it's so hard to
think about doing that.
And we can come back to this.
This is a super loaded
and super touchy topic,
but we can definitely
come back to it
later or in the Q&A session.
I want to switch
gears a little bit
and ask about going from being
a tech nerd to being a gun nerd,
because this is kind of
a transition that I made.
And I was super fascinated.
I covered CES back
when it was COMDEX.
And it was very much elastic
waistbands and giant PDAs.
And it was, like,
nerd central, man.
And I came out of the
PC enthusiast scene,
and we over-clocked, and we
did graphics card benchmarks,
and frames per second.
And we had system wars.
And there was a whole
online kind of geek culture.
And CES has totally
flushed all that out.
Now it's like celebrities,
and it's-- of course,
this is the rise of the
post-PC era and smartphones,
stuff like this.
There are car people at
CES, and Verizon execs.
But anyway, it was
kind of pristine,
sort of nerd paradise
back in the day.
And when I jumped
into gun culture,
my first experience
was covering Shot Show.
This is where I met Chris.
This is right after Newtown, and
I was aware of the black rifle
phenomenon, but was not
really that into it.
But I kind of was
aware enough to know
that there was a
gadget component.
So I got the "Wired"
guys to approve a pitch,
and I went to Shot as part
of the second media crew.
And I agreed to do some blogging
for the Firearm blog as well.
And that got me credentials,
which Shot wasn't really
handing out credentials to
anybody that was not gun press.
CHRIS CHENG: And Shot Show
is the largest gun convention
in Las Vegas every year.
JOHN STOKES: Yes,
it's the CES of guns.
So I was able to get in, and go
and do a bunch of interviews.
And I was so struck.
I was, like, this is like
going back in time 12 years.
I mean, these people are so
nerdily into what they're into.
And they don't even really
care about the press.
I was, like, the last
person anybody really
was just interested
in talking to.
And then when you go
on forums, there's
operating system wars
in the AR-15 world--
the piston versus
direct infringement.
And they call it an
operating system.
There is a feet per second
benchmarks-- FPS instead
of frames per second
for a graphics card.
And so you have benchmark bake
offs, and operating system
wars, and you have people
in different camps.
And there's religious fervor.
CHRIS CHENG: Caliber
controversies.
JOHN STOKES: Caliber
controversies--
it's just as vicious as Mac
versus PC of yesteryear.
And so many similarities,
and I end up
feeling pretty well at home.
But I wanted to get
Chris's take on that,
because I know that you've
made the jump as well.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, it's
been exciting to go
from a place like
Google, where all of us
are so passionate
about technology,
and about making things
better in our world,
and that passion that
you have here at a place
like Google, which really
activates you, right?
You have just tremendous
resources here
at your disposal to do some
really, really great things
in the world.
And I think one of
my biggest concerns
about leaving Google there's
so many intelligent and driven,
smart, capable
people-- would I find
that in the firearms world?
I mean, I literally didn't
know a single person
in the firearms
industry leaving Google.
And it was just this
exciting adventure
of leaving kind of the creature
comforts of three square meals
a day, and delicious Google
cafes, and the shuttles,
and just all-- a
recurring paycheck, just
simple securities like that.
And thankfully, I've
been pleasantly surprised
with the types of
people that I've
met in the shooting community
on the industry side of things,
that again-- very intelligent,
very driven, and very smart
people that are also just very
passionate about the Second
Amendment.
And for me, when I
shot recreationally,
that's all it was, right?
For me, shooting was not
about the Second Amendment.
I didn't care about the
politics, or the policies.
This was before "Top Shot."
I just go to the
range to have fun.
It was just kind of an exciting,
stress relief activity.
But now that I've
been paying attention
to the politics and
the policy discussions,
and realizing that the
Second Amendment is our right
to defend ourselves.
And it's about personal
responsibility,
and not saying that, hey, if
I'm in trouble that I'm just
going to call 9-1-1 and
the police will save me.
It's about being responsible
for your own safety,
for your family's safety,
for the safety of the ones
that you love.
And the tyrannical
government piece
is, I think, a very interesting
kind of conversation piece.
You hear gun people
say, all right,
the Second Amendment is our
way of protecting the people
from tyranny.
And I don't know about you,
but at least, like, before idea
I was studying the Second
Amendment a little bit more,
I hear the word tyranny.
I just think, like 17th century
England with kings, and knights
in armor, and the
tyrannical king
that's laying waste
to his subjects.
And tyranny in
today's time-- tyranny
is all about the unfair
application or abuse
of power on a specific
group of people.
And so, for example, in the
'60s-- in the '50s, '60s, '70s,
when the KKK was really
kind of doing well,
there were sheriffs who were
the Grandmaster of the KKK.
And if a black person needed
the help of the sheriff,
probably forget about it.
And so the fact that
a government entity
like a Sheriff's Department
or Police Department
would not protect an
African-American-- there's
some examples of some
individual police officers
not protecting LGBT
gay pride parades.
This happened in Salt Like City.
That was an individual,
but you can swap that out
for a Police Chief
or a Deputy Sheriff,
or something like that.
And that is, for me, the
modern version of tyranny,
and that's why we need to have
a way to protect ourselves
when the government won't
be there to protect us.
JOHN STOKES: Yeah,
I totally hear that.
And I think if there are
ever robot overlords,
I'm either going
to run and hide,
or I'm going to
become a collaborator.
So don't come to me if
that happens and be,
like, John's a gun person.
He's going to help me
out with my under-- no,
I'm going to sell you out
to the robot overlord.
So I'm going to put this
on YouTube so people know.
I'm warning you in advance.
Anyway, to kind of piggy
back on that, you definitely
overlap multiple communities,
I mean-- Asian community,
tech community, gun
community, gay community.
And the gun community
and the gay community
have historically been at odds.
And I mean, you're now
an NRA commentator,
and these guys had Sarah
Palin at the last--
CHRIS CHENG: Something
caught in your throat?
JOHN STOKES: Yeah, I
almost had to spit.
At the most recent
NRA convention, and so
I know that you get a lot
from-- or you probably
face some backlash
from both sides.
CHRIS CHENG: Sure.
JOHN STOKES: And
I'd love to hear
any kind of stories
or anecdotes.
And I also know that gay
men can really snark it up,
and so you probably have
some great stories there, too
of deadly snark,
or redneck bigotry,
or whatever kind of a--
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, I think
there's a false narrative that
is being told in the media.
So you mentioned historically
that the gay community
and the gun community
are at odds.
And I actually-- I think
that's completely false.
But if all you watch
is the media, then
sure-- that is the narrative
that you continue to hear.
And so for the past two
years since leaving Google,
I've traveled all across the
country to parts of states,
and parts of states I never
imagined myself being in.
But it's been wonderful.
And I've met so many gun
people who are just-- they
are ecstatic when they meet
me and they know that I'm gay.
And I can't tell you
the number of times
that I hear someone say, I'm so
glad that you're representing
the firearms community,
because there
are more people like us that
really welcome anybody that's
interested in
learning how to shoot.
Come out and join us.
And this is a perception
problem that I think the gun
community-- that I'm trying to
counter, because all in all,
sure, I've met a
few-- actually, I
haven't met anybody who's,
like, to my face said, like,
oh you're gay and
you talk-- it's
all just internet
troll nonsense.
Which these days-- look
I managed a product forum
here at Google for
a year and a half.
And like that was my job,
like, manage the trolls.
Occasionally I would feed them,
mostly trying and starve them.
But it just comes
with the territory,
right, to deal with criticism.
And I think the
other kind of thought
to answer your question about
sort of my experiences--
ultimately, for me this is
about encouraging each of us
to live our own truth, and to
be not ashamed of who we are
and what we believe in.
And there's always going to be
people who disagree with you,
right?
If you build an argument
starting with that base,
just knowing that
there's people who
are going to disagree with
you on just everything.
And I used to treat
life to a certain extent
like a popularity contest, like
high school and junior high.
Like, I want to be
friends with everybody.
And to a large extent, I
mean, that is still very much
a strong goal and a
strong drive for me,
is to be nice to people, and to
find ways for us to get along.
But on the other
hand, I'm not willing,
and I'm not going to
compromise who I am
and what I believe in for the
sake of being-- I'll be civil,
but I'm not going to
obviously, go out of my way
to pretend like I like them
if they are not a good person.
So living our own truth is
a real big focus for me,
and encouraging that in others.
JOHN STOKES: So we're kind
of running long on time,
and this is a great sort
of a vein of discussion.
But I want to break out of it,
because we do have the clip.
CHRIS CHENG: Oh, right.
JOHN STOKES: And we have
to get out the clip.
And so I want to
set up the clip,
because as a gun
culture 1.0 person,
you learned that shooting
is about muscle memory,
and it's about talent, and
all this other kind of stuff.
And Chris talks a lot in
his book about visualization
and stress management.
And I am [SQUEAK] what is this?
What kind of a--
like, how do you--
like, I would never
think that this
is important for a marksman--
visualization and stress
management.
But these were kind of the
keys to his sort of come
from nowhere kind of success.
And I want to ask him a question
about that, because I told him,
I said, I feel like your book
should have been called "The
Four-hour Marksman," because
it comes from this kind
of hacker--
CHRIS CHENG: Tim Ferriss.
JOHN STOKES: Yeah,
but not quite.
Training is still
important, but I
want to get a look at Chris in
action doing his visualization,
and the fruit of that.
CHRIS CHENG: Great.
We're going to set
up a projector here.
And so while we're waiting
for the projector to fire up,
I'll do a little
bit of an intro here
to what we're going to see here.
So this was one of
the most thrilling
and harrowing elimination
challenges for me,
where I was going up against
William Bethards, who
is a Marine Corps
rifleman, and he
trains FBI Special
Agents in Quantico.
And so every single FBI
Special Agent over the past-- I
don't know, whatever,
10 years or something--
has gone through his tutelage.
So let me just go
ahead and play it.
It's a five-minute clip.
And enjoy.
JOHN STOKES: Stress management,
ladies and gentlemen.
I almost wet my pants watching
it, and I know how it ends.
So I can't imagine.
And you can see the marksman
just, like, fumbling with it.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, to
kind of talk a little bit
about what was
going on, and sort
of what I talk about in the
book is stress management
and emotional management.
So with that 1860 Henry
rifle that I was shooting,
there's a whole
practice session that
was aired before
the actual event.
And so I knew that
rifle shot high.
So for a lot of guns
that are sighted,
you put your front
sight on the target,
you're going to hit the target.
Well, in this case,
the point of impact
was higher above the target.
And so basically
what that means is I
needed to aim low
to hit my target.
Now when the elimination
challenge first started off,
I was missing high,
high, and high,
and just all that stress that
was building up-- there's
a phrase called the
amygdala hijack, where
the emotional part of
your brain just, like,
literally takes over any
cognitive, rational thinking
abilities.
And so in my mind, like, I
know that this gun shoots high.
I need to shoot lower.
But like a dumb caveman, I just
kept on doing the same thing,
expecting a different result.
And it was really
funny that usually when
Colby, who's the host that you
saw there, when he's narrating
during these challenges, you
just want him to just be quiet.
I don't need to hear you
narrating all my mistakes,
and let me focus on shooting.
But in this specific
challenge, when
you heard him say Chris
is falling behind,
or Chris better pick
up pace, I heard that,
because he was literally
about 12 feet behind me.
But I heard that, and
that snapped me out of it.
And I had this
moment where I just
said, OK, I need
to just recenter.
And for me a big part
of stress management
is pulling on other
experiences where
I've had to deal with stress.
And so at Google dealing
with angry customers--
that was a big part of my job.
Customers would
call in or email.
My Gmail is not working.
Google calendar's not showing
certain events or whatever.
And remaining calm
when a customer is just
screaming and yelling
at you because there's
all sorts of problems-- it's a
hard skill, to focus, to build.
Because the customer's angry,
but you need to stay calm
and just focus on
the task at hand.
So when I was stressed out in
that elimination challenge,
I definitely was pulling
on that Google experience.
And so again, that's like my
cross-disciplinary approach
to problem solving.
And project
management definitely
came forward in helping me win
that elimination challenge.
JOHN STOKES: We're
almost done here,
and I want to throw out one
last quick questions, and--
CHRIS CHENG: Take
some questions.
JOHN STOKES: We'll take some
questions from the audience.
So just a very quick question--
so the Zombie Apocalypse,
man-- what are the
three guns that you're
going to have for the
Zombie Apocalypse?
You know I had to ask it.
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah,
especially with the Ebola
and the Enterovirus D68.
I mean, there's all sorts of
stuff going on these days.
So three guns--
I'm not a prepper,
and I'm not a survivalist, but
being a native Californian,
having an earthquake kit
is just like standard.
And now that I'm in the
gun world, adding guns-- so
your earthquake
basically just doubles
as Doomsday disaster kit.
So sort of there's
a holy trinity,
if you will, of pistol,
shotgun, and rifle.
But I really would just
say there's really not
much of a discussion
about the rifle.
It should be an
AR-15 for the rifle.
I'm a 12-gauge shotgun.
I would say there's this
huge controversy around what
is the right shotgun for
a survival situation?
I would say pump Remington
870 or Mossberg 500.
They're reliable.
You've got capacity in it.
And then with the
pistol, just get--
I'd say a revolver's
a really good choice,
but I'm a Glock guy, so
I'd have my Glock 34.
JOHN STOKES: Cool.
So do you guys have questions?
We could take some
questions from the audience.
I guess I should
grab a mic here.
AUDIENCE: That we had a
serious suicide problem.
And the host was just
all about anti-guns.
And he saw it as an opportunity
to push his anti-gun stance,
while the person
who was recognizing
this problem of suicide, was,
like, listen-- in Oregon,
it's really bad.
It's actually, of all
gun deaths, 80% or 85%
are suicides.
Is that something
maybe we can address?
How do we get that
out there more?
How do we make that part
of the conversation?
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
And I think what I
want to encourage
is that each of
us as individuals
has a lot of power over
dictating or directing
the conversation that happens in
our local communities, and then
county-wide, statewide,
and nationwide.
And especially with the web--
a single voice, a single story,
can have a tremendous
resonating impact.
And so my answer
is, we need to talk
about this in any
appropriate forum, where
we come in with the knowledge,
and the facts, and the stories.
Because arguments
can't just be dry,
factual, logical arguments.
There has to be an emotional
connection and a grounding.
Because that is this combination
of logic and emotion-- for me,
I think that is-- finding
that sweet spot for how
to convey a compelling argument.
And I think suicide prevention
is-- it's not just about guns.
I would add the word
just, because yes, guns
are a part of it.
Like, I don't want to make it
seem like extreme, like it's
just a mental health issue.
Guns are part of the problem.
But one thing that I look
back at my experience here
at Google, and I worked
with a lot of engineers
as a part of my role,
where it's, like,
I would hear customer problems.
And we're relaying
information to engineers
who are trying to figure out
the root cause of a problem.
And that root cause
analysis and approach
has always just stayed with me.
Because the customer
may say something like,
I'm seeing something in Gmail
where I click on a button,
and my messages
disappear-- whatever.
We relay that information
on to the engineers,
and the engineering
team's looking into this.
And the problem may not
even lie with Gmail.
It may be related to the
Google account framework,
and causing some
sort of problem.
So you have all of these
potential red herrings
out there.
I see a Gmail problem.
I see a suicide
problem with guns,
and therefore, it
must be a gun problem.
When in actuality,
the suicide problem
has its own root causes, right?
The gun is not causing people
to kill themselves, right?
There is something
else, and deeper,
with that particular topic.
And so again, just
the more conversations
that we can have that
are driven by facts,
but also by anecdotes
and narratives, I think,
is an effective approach.
And this is a long, hard slog.
There's not going to be
any immediate solution
that we're going to see.
This is going to take decades.
And this is the
kind of commitment
that I have to
this kind of issue.
And I know there's
lots of other people
that are also committed
to reducing gun violence
and preventing suicides.
AUDIENCE: Back when you were
here and going through "Top
Shot," and doing
[INAUDIBLE], which is great,
it was super
exciting, I remember
at one point you shared,
like, some trick sheet.
And I don't want to say
it was like light bulb,
but it was something like that.
And I remember looking at that
and for one, I was kind of,
like, oh, my god, this guy
shared what his goals for life
are.
This is amazing, because this
seems private and all that.
But it was really inspiring.
And I seem to vaguely remember
there was some stuff in there
about maybe you want
to go into politics.
CHRIS CHENG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And I don't
want to try and hold you
to something from
several years ago,
because it was a different
time and everything.
But do you still think
that maybe one day you'll
pursue that route?
Because I know I'd vote for you.
CHRIS CHENG: Sure, well, thanks.
Yeah, that's definitely
still in the cards for me.
But it's funny
that you mentioned
the personal development plan,
or otherwise known as a PDP.
That's actually in Chapter
One of the book, which
is talking about
why learn to shoot.
And how does the specific
marksmanship skill sets
and related skills-- trigger
control, sight alignment,
sight picture-- these
are marksmanship skills,
but they also feed into hard
work, discipline, mind, body,
soul control, and mindfulness.
And how do you effectively
leverage your whole skill set
into a career path?
And so in the book, I talk
about how marksmanship for me--
I mean, unexpectedly.
This wasn't something
that I'm, like, hey,
I'm working at Google.
I'm going to study guns
and go do a career in guns.
But it's how to really, again,
just tie this all together,
and be happy, and be
fulfilled in your career path,
and know that the work
that you're doing today
is building to your own
personal and professional goals,
and having a plan around that.
So quick background--
part of my role at Google
was also leadership training,
and also management training.
So if you've taken
True Colors, which
is like a whittled-down
version of Myers-Briggs,
I was a True Colors facilitator.
And I was a career
coach for my team.
And so I think the
main point, though,
especially related
to your question,
is knowing what you
want to get out of life,
and being very specific--
as specific as you can,
and sharing that with people.
And look, I'll tell you.
So I actually have
a Google short link
to my PDP in the book.
And I may not hit all my
goals that I have out there,
but there's some really
lofty stuff out there.
And obviously at a
place like Google,
I mean, we dream big for
ourselves, for the company,
for the potential that
Google products have
to do good in the world.
And I think it's just
very natural for us
to want the same.
We want to optimize and maximize
our own personal happiness.
So thanks for bringing up
the question, because it's
actually related to the book.
JOHN STOKES: So we're
out of time, but Chris,
did you have any kind
of final thoughts
that you want to share briefly?
CHRIS CHENG: Yeah, so I
think just to really, really
bring home the point of
living your own truth.
That, I think, is
just so important.
And this whole gun stuff,
and all the gay stuff,
with same-sex marriage, and
all these assault weapons,
and the 30-round magazine
controversies-- these
are hard conversations to
have with a lot of people.
And we can't shy away from
the things that we believe in.
And again, just
live your own truth,
and whatever that truth
is, make sure people know.
And for me, I mean,
that's just been,
I think, a huge key to my
own personal happiness.
And I hope it is for
other people as well.
JOHN STOKES: Thank
you, Chris, and thank
you guys for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS CHENG: Thanks, everybody.